ich habe in ihre das genießer herz
ansprechenden auslage einige
delikatessen der lokalen
fleischzubereitung entdeckt und ich
kämpfe noch mit mir selbst mit welcher
dieser und schmeichelnden kostbarkeiten
ich mein gaumen glück versuchen will
wir sind in ihrem einladenden
schaufenster aber auch hier in dieser
liebevoll bereiteten theken auslage
einige wurst käse und fleischwaren ins
auge gestochen und ich hadere noch ein
wenig mit meiner entscheidung ob der
exquisiten auswahl ist loosli kommt erst
[Musik]
sind sie eine leberwurst so for me
bitte was ist los
draußen wir fast mit frank rost
ist
das war super sache endlich mal
verstehen
schnell und effektiv bayerisch lernen
kommt dem rad bayerisch kurs babbel
bayerisch lernen leicht gemacht
ich habe aus euch ja gesagt ja du hast
gesagt
nur drei wochen bayerisch kurs und ich
besorge euch hier die besten fleisch
käse brötchen
[Musik]
wurde die 330 kilometer in sieben
präfekturen
wenn die bayern eines können dann ist
das fleisch käse du sagst das handeln
[Musik]
[Applaus]